what do you like to listen to people
talk about anime no it depends on where
going on in the world
or with somebody saying or some [__] I
might want to go see they see what they
said in the podcast myself
so I can feel like how I probably feel
about the situation type [__] you
somebody like someone said something
about you nah just in general we'll be
speaking about some [__]
you know you might see somebody to bash
somebody on Instagram they say oh he
said that I go see what he said yeah
cause you can't just trust the headline
yeah yeah no you can't never try no [__]
like that that's some real [__] [__] I
probably got now speaking some real
[__] [__] you never uh said what your
favorite anime ever was man
I thought we were gonna run around that
[__] that [__] up
my favorite anime set
I mean I feel like that was everybody
favorite anime dragon ball yeah like as
a kid woman yeah Dragon Ball was the one
yeah yeah as a kid yeah yeah but now my
favorite anime probably like
I fought with one punch man
that [__] what is the premise
my son watches that what's it about
there's no little is there a little I'm
trying to I'm trying to think
it's about getting punched once
let me Google it one bunch
he basically like he like
I don't know because it's time for his
head on just straight just punch like
one punch out tight [__] you know what
I'm saying but
like majority of all the people he
really get into it with
is it called one punch man yeah one
punch man
oh I see he's like a ball dude yeah he
ball here
this fool looks like [__]
this fool looks like goddamn he ain't
got no superpowers either
so he just oh look at him when he hit
him like he's like a nerdy dude yeah
yeah
so why so is he
trying this I don't know how the [__]
he's trying to sell to be be got down
that goddamn so he's a super so it's
about a superhero who's normal
yeah like you're a human basically yeah
you ever watch The Boondocks The
Boondocks yeah yeah
Boondocks is amazing Boondock oh I would
be that [__]
two seasons of The Boondocks are good
the last season was a little because the
main Rider quit yeah man I like what's
your favorite character
I mean I love
I love Riley
right I mean Gramps is funny
I like oh oh what's the racist black
dude who hates yeah I know who I like
Uncle work wait no Uncle records I said
Clayton Bixby that's Dave Chappelle's
scary Uncle Ruckus yeah Uncle reckon
that probably is the finest [__]
on that [__] bro that [__] stupid as
hell he said anything he don't give a
damn hold on bro Uncle Ruckus
I have so my best friend's brother works
on
you got to hear this drop
if I have it
this is the actual actor this is it hold
on hey America this is
welcome and even though he dressed and
sound like a donkey you are listening to
the greatest white man oh Lord they
smell like Financial polish and lemon
zest God bless his wife
[Laughter]
because the guy who voices a few of the
characters including Uncle Ruckus yeah
he did a drop he was doing radio drops
and [__] so I was like bro I need a
Uncle Ruckus drop
yeah man that [__] funny hell man you
seen the one when he was a little kid
yes I see them all that [__] was so
goddamn funny boy yeah I like uh I like
the uh the the episode where the the
[__] lawyer dude
his wife gets snatched by Usher
do you remember the episodes Usher
snatches this dude's [__] and then he
goes and hires a pimp named slickback to
try to get his girl back
is [__] hilarious by the way oh oh
the pimp
named slickback yeah I know the little
pimp with the pink with the little the
look yeah yeah I know they can't win but
yeah yeah the parent will find it here
too oh so good man so good